hi I'm Alex Amancio the creative
director for Assassin's Creed unity in
this feature we will show how unity
delivers a fully systemic city unlike
any other our ambition was to recreate
eighteenth century Paris filled with a
unique cast of characters beautiful
locations and the fresh gameplay
experience that offers unparalleled
scope of activity we've ensured that
every area of Paris has its own identity
by dramatically changing architectural
styles and NPC behavior each Parisian
district has been brought to life along
with its own special character this
unprecedented density and variety kick
interactivity to a new level and
introduced play styles never before seen
in an assassin's creed game you might
find yourself embroiled in a murder
mystery by stumbling upon a trail of
clues investigate more and you might
just catch a glimpse into the depths of
the Parisian underworld when I found a
body floating in the river but the wound
on his chest only a custom blade could
do that solve the crime and get a unique
rewarding try the revamped contract
system rather than just assassinations
these are now the Paris stories fully
fledged out narrative quests that we let
players tackle from any direction
rapidly thickening plot treasure hunts
will lead you from the deepest category
for the highest landmark as you try to
uncover all of paris's sequence
we've also added heist missions to unity
which are playable with friends these
missions lets you infiltrate Paris's
most inaccessible areas in search of
treasure reach the loot whilst avoiding
detection using any means necessary for
the stealth here you are the bigger the
reward each playthrough is a different
experience as guard paths layouts and
loot are randomized each time we've also
introduced the cavity of this is a hub
for all of our nose assassin activities
and a home for all your social features
as well as managing profiles
customization and trophies this area
contains all the training facilities an
assassin can never be too well prepared
better to practice here in safety this
was only a glimpse of the dozens of
hours of content awaiting you in
Assassin's Creed unity by creating the
largest densest and most realistic Paris
ever we offer players a chance to
explore like never before make history
Assassin's Creed unity pre-order now for
the explosive chemical revolution
mission get a season pass save thirty
percent on eight hours of new content
includes a new campaign more missions
and weapons and a new downloadable game
pre-order now available November 11th